what's up everybody
it's an exciting day as we found out
that the first official trailer for
Captain Marvel will be premiering
Tuesday September 18th on Good Morning
America as soon as it gets put out
online I'll try to get it up for you the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway still
continues I will be picking a winner
tomorrow Saturday so if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is be a subscriber like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
with the trailer coming out on Tuesday
we're hoping to get a better look at and
get more information about Jude Law's
character since the very beginning of
the production of Captain Marvel Jude
Law has been said to be playing the role
of Marvel but as of recently many people
believe that he is actually not going to
be playing Marvel this is largely due to
the Entertainment Weekly interviews that
were posted online so in all of these
interview questions and all photo
descriptions that Entertainment Weekly
posted they all avoid saying who the
character is Jude Law has actually went
to pretty great lengths to avoid saying
who his character is in one interview
when asked about it he said yes it's
been reported I'm playing marvel I'm not
going to confirm or deny that putting
emphasis on reported as and it's not
confirmed it's not denied but yeah
people have reported that I'm playing
marvel that doesn't mean he is and then
we had the first look by II W where they
carefully avoided naming his character
and one of the photos that he's in that
II W released the description of this
photo is titled a mysterious mentor and
underneath it says Jude Law plays the
commander of Star Force again
intentionally avoiding telling us who
his character is so why all the secrecy
well it's actually believed now that
he's going to be the villain in Captain
Marvel and his character isn't Marvel
but it's yon rug this is interesting
because Marvel and Yan raag are two
completely different characters in fact
Yan Rock spends a good majority of his
time trying to kill Marvel jaan raghav
much like Ronan the accuser is another
Cree fanatic and he actually partners
with Ronan the accuser and tries to take
control of the creep trying to lead them
back into their warlike ways he was
actually who took the Kree to earth in
the comics so right now all we really
know about Jude Law's character is that
he's a mysterious commander of Star
Force and that he's a devout warrior
with a deep-rooted belief in the divine
leadership of the Kree people doesn't
sound like Marvel actually sounds more
like you on rug now it has been stated
in the e W interview that Captain Marvel
is not an origin story this is quite
interesting because in the comics Carol
Danvers actually gets her powers from an
explosion that happens while Marvel and
Yan rug are fighting this happens on
earth at Cape Canaveral but it's already
been stated that Captain Marvel will
take place in space right away she will
already be part of Star Force when the
movie starts if you want to know more
about the story between jaan raghav
Marvel you can check it out in the link
above it also talks about Captain
Marvel's origins and I'll put it at the
end of this video as well so it
definitely doesn't seem like they're
following the storyline from the comics
which is fine but the question remains
who is Jude Law's character you can see
the two side-by-side in this photo that
Entertainment Weekly published and you
can also see them together in this photo
as well it seems like in the movie
they're going to spend a lot of time
with each other so it would not surprise
me if they're planning on taking over
the Kree bringing them back to their
warlike ways and attack earth in which
case Captain Marvel would step in and
battle them because we know Ronan the
accuser survives because he's in
guardians of the galaxy so perhaps
Captain Marvel ends up fighting Jude
Law's character in the final battle and
she ends up killing him as of right now
nothing is really known about his
character but it does seem like they've
gone to very great lengths to avoid
saying who it is but as of right now Yan
Roxy me be everybody's best guess so
what do you all think do you think Jude
Law is playing Marvel tour just trying
to be really secretive or do you think
that he's playing somebody else let me
know what you think in the comments
below and again don't forget about the
giveaway I'll be choosing a winner
tomorrow if you'd like to enter all
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you